ja willkommen zu aktuellen Vorlesung
Grundprobleme der praktischen
Philosophie möchte zunächst auf eine
Videoaufzeichnung von mir Hinweisen oben
rechts Martin Link hinein wo es um das
Thema philosophieren Computerspiel gegen
den habe ich auf der für Cologne
gehalten
jetzt möchte ich zu Beginn wie immer auf
das begriffsnetz eingehen das hat sich
mittlerweile schon sehr weit entwickelt
überspringe die anfängliche
Unterscheidungen die an der Person
ansetzen und dem Handlungsbegriff den
willensbegriff Vernunftbegriff und auch
im Problem von Willen Schwächen
Selbsttäuschung wir sind in den letzten
Sitzungen auf das freiheitsproblem
eingegangen
ich machte auch oben rechts in den Kreis
zu dieser Vorlesung Freiheit keinen
positiven negative Freiheit
unterschieden werden Handlungsfreiheit
ins Freiheit war Willensfreiheit ist ein
sehr zentrales Thema der
Autonomiebegriff fängt damit zusammen
dann gibt es drei Formen
des Verhältnisses
unserer Freiheit des Willens zur
determination zur Notwendigkeit und zur
Interferenz Indifferenz heißt unsere
freie Willensentscheidung ist überhaupt
nicht determiniert könnte auch sagen in
der terminismus
also völlige Unentschiedenheit
dann gibt es da runter die kommen
artikelistische Position und die
inkompatibilistische Position die stellt
sich die Frage ob Willensfreiheit und
determination miteinander vereinbar sind
oder der Feminismus jedenfalls
determination aller Zustände der Welt
der kompatibilismus sagt das ist möglich
willenseit und vollständigen Geld und
der Naturgesetze ist vereinbar
kompatibel der inkompatibilismus
bestreitet das auch zwei verschiedene
Weisen ein Mann den man sagt bitte
terminismus ist wahr er geht vollständig
und deswegen gibt es keine
Willensfreiheit oder die andere
Perspektive der libertarierismus sagt
willenfreiheit und Determinismus
vertragen sich nicht allerdings ist die
Ansicht das alles strengte terminiert
ist falsch
also sind frei das ist eine besonders
wichtige und nicht so leicht zu erkennen
die unterscheiden
wir haben dann uns noch mit Emotionen
gefasst der Liebe wir haben gesehen dass
bei Harry Frank wird Liebe und und
Rationalität Zusammenhängen ähnlich so
bekannt die Achtung das hängt natürlich
dann wiederum mit der moralischen
Motivation zusammen welche Gefühle
Emotionen sind geeignet und zum
moralischen Handeln zu motivieren
die letzten Sitzung sind wir auf
Normativität eingegangen Normativität
kann ganz verschiedene Dinge betreffen
einem schwachen Sinne nicht moralische
Normativität juristisch die Gesetze
geltendes Grundgesetz gilt aber auch
ästhetische Normativität was ist die
Bedingung für ein schönes Kunstwerk dann
gibt es auch die Stärke von Normativität
das ist die moralische Normativität da
hängt natürlich wieder ganz kategorische
Imperativ damit strengt ist der wird
jung hat und das das Thema der heutigen
Vorlesung des Verhältnis von sein sollen
problematisiert er sagt vom sein zum
sollen also von deskriptiven
Beschreibung der Welt zu normativen
Beschreibung da gibt es eine Luft diese
Übergang ist nicht so trivial
die nur ein Versuch des 20 Jahrhundert
hat daran angeknüpft von einem
naturalistischen Fehlschluss gesprochen
den wir begehen wenn wir moralische oder
welche Normativität auch immer durch
natürliche Prädikat versuchen zu
erklären
heute wollen wir uns nochmal mit
moralischen Normativität befassen dann
aber vor allem mit dem Problem von
Zahlen und sollen und am Schluss gebe
ich noch ein paar Informationen zur
Klausur
das Verhältnis von sein und sollen
betrifft die moralische Normativität vor
allem und hier hat David Hume ein sehr
zentrales Zitat wieder
verfasst und seine
einzig besteht darin dass unmoralisches
handeln und zur 5 nicht zu wieder läuft
das haben wir schon mal gesehen die
Vernunft kann uns auch nicht zum
moralischen Handeln motivieren und jetzt
muss man sich fragen wie kann man dann
Normativität moralische begründen
ein ganz zentrales Zitat bringe ich
jetzt hier ich lese es mal ein bisschen
vor es sagt in jedem Moralsystem das
eine bisher vorkam habe ich immer
bemerkt dass der Verfasser eine Zeit
lang in der gewöhnlichen
Betrachtungsweise vorhergeht dass da
sein Gottes feststellt oder Beobachtung
über menschliche Dinge hervorbringt
diese Beobachtung über menschliche Dinge
sind deskriptive Urteile X ist der Fall
y ist der Fall und so weiter plötzlich
und deswegen habe ich jetzt fett
markiert plötzlich sagt jung werde ich
damit überrascht dass mir anstatt der
üblichen Verbindung von Wort mit ist und
ist nicht also diesen gewöhnlichen
Betrachtung der menschlichen Dinge kein
Satz mehr begegnet in dem nicht ein
sollte oder sollte nicht sich wendet
dieser Wechsel von sein oder sei nicht
so sollte nicht vollzieht sich
unmerklich aber er ist von größter
Wichtigkeit die sollte und sollte nicht
drückt eine neue Beziehung oder
Behauptung aus muss also
notwendigerweise beachten erklärt werden
gleichzeitig muss ein Grund angegeben
werden für etwas das sonst ganz
unbegreiflich scheint nämlich dafür wie
diese neue Beziehung zurückgeführt
werden kann auf andere die von den ganz
verschieden sind also wie können wir den
Übergang von deskriptiven urteilen auf
normative Urteile hin bewerkstelligen
das ist eine ganz spannende Frage human
hat noch ein zentrales Zitat was jetzt
hier in der Natur betrifft er sagt
einstweilen ist vielleicht hinsichtlich
der Definition von natürlich und
natürlich noch die Bemerkung Platze das
nichts und philosophischer sein kann als
jene Theorien die behaupten die Tugend
sei gleichbedeutend mit dem natürlich
das Laster mit dem unnatürlich
also man könnte jetzt auf diese Weise
argumentieren es ist nur natürlich wenn
man tierische Produkte zu sich nimmt das
haben die Menschen immer schon gemacht
das aber wirklich dann auch gut ist ist
eine andere Frage also es gibt viele
Urteile die beschreiben was ist was auch
natürlich ist die bringen mit sich nicht
unbedingt eine Normativität
natürliche Normativität da gibt es eine
große Debatte drüber auf die wie der
nächsten Vorlesung Sitzung eingehen
werden ob die Natur selbst in sich Werte
und Normen enthält sind dass wir eine
natürliche Gutheit
ich sehe das sehr kritisch mit der mich
und hier hat er ein zentrales Zitat
gegeben
ja also der sein sollen Fehlschluss sagt
jung der wird sehr häufig begangen wir
können nämlich nach ihrem nicht
unmittelbar von deskriptiven Prämissen
von Prämissen die Aussagen wird was ist
auf normative Prämissen oder Sätze
schließen wir brauchen Zusatz Prämissen
und diesen Schluss gültig zu machen
sogar auch dann schlüssig zu machen wenn
die Prämissen da sind diese
zusatzbremsen müssen dann aber normativ
sein wenn auch vielleicht auf schwache
weiß
er sagten noch etwas und zwar diesmal
Immanuel Kant ganz wie ich jung sagte
das sollen drückt eine Art von
Notwendigkeit und Verknüpfung mit
Gründen aus die der ganzen Natur sonst
nicht vorkommt der Verstand kann von
dieser Natur nur erkennen was da heißt
oder gewesen ist oder sein wird es ist
unmöglich das etwas darin anders sein
soll als es in allen diesen
Zeitverhältnissen in der Tat ist ja das
sollen wenn man bloß den Lauf der Natur
vor Augen hat hat ganz und da keine
Bedeutung wir können gar nicht fragen
was Naturgeschehen soll ebenso weniger
als was für Eigenschaften ein Zirkel
haben soll sowas darin geschieht oder
welche Eigenschaften der letzte hat das
sind nur despektive Auskünfte keine
normativen das sollen
es gebe ich ein Beispiel für einen sein
sollen es Fehlschluss also die Frage ist
sollen wir die nicht menschliche Natur
schützen es könnte man so argumentieren
die Natur ist organische Fasten besitzt
Einordnung alles ist schön zweckmäßig
gestaltet
daraus könnte man jetzt schließen also
sollen wir die Natur schützen das folgt
aber nicht daraus was der organischen
Verfasstheit soll kein Sohn
man müsste also dieses Argument etwas
erweitern etwa folgendermaßen die Natur
ist doch gar nicht verfasst
um auf diese Konklusion zu kommen die
Natur verfolgt eigene Zwecke
eine Natur die Zwecke verfolgt setzt
Werte
eine Welt mit Zwecken ist besser als
eine Welt ohne die organische Natur ist
also schutzbedürftig und daraus folgt
dann vielleicht mal mit weiteren
Prämissen dass wir Menschen die Natur
schützen sollen ein solches Argument hat
Hans Jonas in seiner Schrift über die
Verantwortungsethik das Prinzip Hoffnung
entwickelt
es kommen auf einen weiteren Denker des
Verhältnisses von seinem sollen zu
sprechen Gino
hat ein Schrift verfasst Prinzip ja
Ethiker im Prinzipien betätigt ethische
Prinzipien und die Thesen die ja
vertritt lauten wir können den Begriff
des Guten beziehungsweise des Prädikat
gut eigentlich gar nicht definieren wenn
wir glauben gut durch angenehm oder
sonstige Prädikate definieren zu können
dann unterliegen wir einen
naturalistischen Fehlschluss
naturalisticalacy
ich bin ein paar Zitate die das belegen
er sagt wenn ich gefragt werde was ist
gut so laut meine Antwort das Gut gut
ist und damit ist die Sache erledigt
oder wenn er mich fragt wie ist gut zu
definieren so ist meine Antwort das ist
nicht definiert werden kann und mehr ist
darüber nicht zu sagen
ich will sagen dass gut ein einfacher
Begriff ist so wie Geld man einfacher
Begriff ist dass man so wie man
unmöglich jemanden der es noch nicht
kennt der ist nicht schon kennt erklären
kann was gelb ist diesem auch nicht
erklären kann was gut ist
als gut ist wie eine Farbe etwas was man
kennen muss was man gesehen haben muss
gespürt haben muss was man aber nicht
begrifflich weiter definieren kann
deswegen sagte auch gut ist im
entscheidenden Sinn des Wortes keine
Definition fähig
in diesem Sinne zieht sich gut jeglicher
Definition da ist einfach ist und keine
Teile hat
es ist eine jener zahllosen Gegenstände
Definition unfähig sind weil sie die
letzten Begriffe sind mit dem alles was
definierbar ist definiert werden muss
der Begriff des Guten ist ein
Grundbegriff der deswegen nicht mehr
weiter analysiert oder definiert werden
kann
ja so viel zur Thematik von seinen
sollen es Fehlschluss naturalistischen
Fehlschluss jetzt möchte ich noch ein
paar Informationen zur Klausur geben die
findet am 18 Juli 2021 Start um 15:45
Uhr und es gibt je nach erforderlichen
Leistungspunkten 30 minütige Klausur 50
oder 80
in der 80 benötigen Klausur werde ich
zwei verschiedene Fragen stellen
hier gibt es noch Informationen zu
Anmeldung bitte bei Frau gule
Sekretariat bitte spätestens bis 14 Tage
vor der Prüfungstermin anmelden und
diese Punkte mitteilen die hier genannt
ja ich hatte gesagt es werden zwei Typen
von Fragen
gebracht in dieser 18 nötigen Klausur
und dazu möchte ich noch etwas sagen
worauf man achten sollte alle
verwendeten Begriffe sollten genau
geklärt und abgegrenzt werden
gegeneinander dazu hilft das
begriffsnetz
geben Sie ihm auch geeignete Beispiele
zu erläutern
schreiben Sie im ganzen
zusammenhängenden Sätzen es gibt zwei
Fragetypen Frage sind Wissensfragen
Diskussion zu erörterungsaufgaben drohen
konnte Argumente für eine bestimmte
Fragestellung ich gebe jetzt mal ein
Beispiel des Typs a welche drei Probleme
ergeben sich hinsichtlich moralische
Normativität erläutern sie eines davon
Kinder es hat in den letzten Vorlesung
behandelt die gibt es das
Erkenntnisproblem wie kann ich
Normativität begründen
gibt es geltungsprobleme für wen gilt
Normativität für wen nicht
das Begründungsproblem wie kann ich sie
begründen und rechtfertigen natürlich
ist das Ergebnis Problem auch wie kann
ich noch mal erkennen
moralische normative jetzt ein Beispiel
ich kann dadurch begründet werden dass
sie Anspruch auf Rationalität
Universität und Autonomie
sie erhebt ein rationalitätanspruch das
was vernünftig ist sollte auch getan
werden arzneiität besitzt also eine
spezifische Form von Gesetzlichkeit sei
es instrumentell oder moralisch das
hatten wir auch im Begriff selbst eine
andere Frage ist lautet worin besteht
der Unterschied zwischen wünschen
zweiter Stufen und Koalitionen zweiten
Stufen nach Frankfurt eine ganz
klassische Frage da könnte jetzt darauf
antworten Wünsche oder desires zweiter
Stufe sind Wünsche die sie auch wünschte
erster Stufe der Objekt Ebene reflexiv
beziehen ich kann man das können Sie ein
Beispiel bringen ich kann zum Beispiel
wünschen Wunsch zu haben ein
erfolgreiches Philosophie studieren und
nicht den Wunsch das Studium abzubrechen
Munition zweite Stufe sind Wünsche
zweiter Stufe die handlungs wirksam sind
die sich als verpflichten
handlungswirksam bedeutet dass sie nicht
nur ein bestimmten Wunsch habe sind ich
möchte dass dieser Wunsch auch
handlungswirksam ist ein will ist seine
handlungswirksamer Wunsch er hängt auch
natürlich damit die zu unterscheiden und
zusammen
Personen sind Wesen die volition zweiter
Stufe ausbilden können one-ton
strebrafter können keine volition 2
Stufe ausbilden obwohl für wohl sie
vielleicht Wünsche zweiter Stufe haben
können jetzt will ich noch ein Beispiel
ist zu spät geben es ist schon etwas
komplizierter so schwierig wird die
Frage dann aber nicht in der Klasse sein
inwiefern verträgt sich Willensfreiheit
mit der Position des initialismus
einleiten Willensfreiheit bedeutet im
Gegensatz zu Handlungsfreiheit dass ich
mein Geld selbst bestimmen können muss
in der terminismus bedeutet das meine
bildungsentscheidung nicht prädete mir
das überhaupt definiert ist für den
interfeminismus spricht das man
bezüglich der Willensfreiheit für ihn
kompatibilismus argumentieren kann und
nach sich Willen nicht mit dem
Determinismus
denn wenn vor meiner Geburt alle
ereignet sind z.B durch Naturgesetze
dann kann ich meinen Handel nicht frei
sein das ist sogenannte Konsequenz ab du
musst also mein Handeln entscheiden ein
Entscheidungsspiel deine haben
verschiedene Optionen haben und ich darf
nicht von vorne an auf einen entschieden
sein sondern muss alternative
Möglichkeit der Wahl haben ich bestimme
nur durch mich selbst was ich will und
werde durch keine andere Faktoren
Argumente gegen den Interessen
der besteht die bestehen darin dass ich
für meine freiwillensentscheidung auch
immer bestimmte Gründe brauche wenn es
gar keine determinierenden Faktoren für
mein Handel gibt dann handelt es sich
dabei ob Bluse Willkür diesen Begriff
haben wir auch diskutiert wenn der
indetermin ist gelten soll dann
unterlege ich im Falle meiner freien
Entscheidung nicht die Naturgesetz dies
aber wird bedeuten dass ich in meinen
freien Entscheidung außerhalb der Natur
natürlich naturalistisch
Naturwissenschaft beschreibbar Natur
existieren dieser ist unglaublich weil
ich ja natürlich ist und biologisches
Wesen bin der mein Körper der durch die
Naturwissenschaft sehr gut erklärbar ist
wieso sollte dann meine Entscheidung
nicht dadurch auch erklärbar sein ja das
waren zwei drei mögliche
Fragen bezüglich der Klausur vielen Dank
für die Aufmerksamkeit wir gehen dann
Interesse ins noch mal genau auf solche
Fragen nein